our friend Kyle kolinsky from secular
talk uh talked about this really just
bogus and bizarre interview that Hillary
Clinton's campaign manager gave let's go
to kyles coverage of it and the clip and
then I have some thoughts Hillary
Clinton's campaign manager went on CNN
and he wanted to remind us of how
perfect she is people don't like the
idea of money going to the Clinton
Foundation in exchange for access to the
vent former Secretary of State I mean
you can understand why that would
trouble people absolutely and and it's
not true I'm again I'm glad you raised
the question because people should
understand that never took place the
Secretary Clinton always met the highest
ethical standards when she was Secretary
of State when she was united states
senator there were systems put in place
to prevent exactly what you're talking
about and again the Russians illegally
stole these emails they're selectively
dumping them out I can't even verify
whether the actual content in them is
real but this is the conversation they
want us to have versus how Hillary's
going to create job no those things are
linked those things are related what
he's explaining there is hey she takes a
lot of money from these people and then
she does favors for them and he's like
well that's distracting from what she's
gonna do in office no that's that's
raising a concern about what she might
do in office if she taking money from
all these special interest she's gonna
do the bidding of those special
interests and snub the constituents he's
know that you're distracting from his
she stood has the highest ethical
standards excuse you but see this is
this is what I'm so averse to and this
is why I have to keep doing these
stories on Hillary Clinton and how
shitty she is is that like it again it's
one thing if you come out there and you
say hey man let me make a well-reasoned
lesser of two evils arguments for you
and explain how whether or not you like
it it's gonna either be Donald Trump or
Hillary Clinton and wins like that's
what's going to happen whether or not
you acknowledge it whether or not you in
Allah it is irrelevant that's what's
going to happen so hey here's why
Hillary Clinton is better and let me lay
it out in detail let me explain all the
areas where she's wrong and terrible we
pull an M&M from 8 mile and explain
everything wrong about my candidate uh
and then explain to you why it's still
the right thing to go in that direction
but people aren't doing that
I get it this is her campaign manager so
he's gonna try to pretend my dream the
best thing ever but it's so disingenuous
that you go oh I don't trust anything
you say about anything ever because I
know you're lying to me you're lying to
everybody's face with this so I think
Kyle's making a really good point here
and people know if you watch this show
that I've made abundantly clear that I
am NOT some Hillary Clinton cheerleader
that I have made one of these
calculations where I've looked at Gary
Johnson and I've looked at jill stein
and I've made a combination of a sort of
practical assessment and an assessment
of the policies and qualifications to
even hold this position and I've decided
I'm going to vote for Hillary Clinton
not because Hillary Clinton being the
next president is some big progressive
rah rah we won and now everything's
going to be super liberal and great but
merely because Hillary Clinton is
president is the most likely scenario
that would open the door to progressives
pushing for more progressive policies
which I believe the country is more
primed to do then uh in the last hundred
plus years however what really bothers
me about Robbie mook going on CNN and
saying Hillary Clinton has the highest
ethical standards listen maybe Hillary
Clinton didn't deliberately do something
that she knew was obvious skating and uh
I guess sketchy to use a term right
forget about illegal with the email
server but just she was trying to sort
of shield whatever we don't know for
sure maybe she did maybe she did we're
not talking about the FBI illegality
investigation into the illegality of it
now but why go to the hyperbole where
you say this is the person with the
highest ethical standards of anyone that
I've ever seen it just doesn't make it
believable and that's exactly why I
think although i disagree i think Kyle's
voting for Jill Stein I'm not totally
sure but I believe he is last last uh I
heard he was voting for Jill Stein I'm
not voting for Jill Stein I'm voting for
Hillary Clinton neither of our vote is
really going to matter if I voted for
Jill Stein in Massachusetts Hillary's
going to win if Kyle voted for Hillary
Clinton or jill stein in New York
Hillary's going to win not going to make
a difference electoral II but I complete
agree with what Kyle is saying which is
when you show up on CNN and in the midst
of real controversy over the emails fine
FBI investigation not illegal but still
it is a controversy and it is something
that is concerning to say oh there's
nothing here at all this is the most
ethical person period with the highest
standards it makes it so that I just
don't believe anything Robbie mook says
and generally even if you're talking
about surrogates on the left or right
whether it's Kellyanne Conway or Robbie
mugre whoever these are the page Hills
right if you're saying Oh David Pakman
is a page she'll because of his comments
about Hillary Clinton uh number 1 i'm
certainly not getting paid for talking
about Hillary Clinton uh uh and and
number two my support for Hillary
Clinton is very conditional and it is
very very specific in terms of what I
think would be achieved through a
Clinton presidency so I completely
sympathize with Kyle here and I think
his analysis is absolutely spot-on you
can check out the entire clip over on
Kyle's channel by using the link in the
description for this video